set up this is a valentine Ferry and
he's you will talk about their phone
limits and large independent sets in
uniform random core graphs yeah so core
is very important core graphs is very
important so tell us all about it yeah
so thank you very much thank you for the
introduction and thank you for the
organizer I'm really happy to be here
and I really enjoyed all the talk so far
I hope I enjoy the next one also
so this is a joint work with a series of
order Feathering by cinematical
microdermotta Lucas
and yeah we were we are studying this
random Core group so I don't know if you
know what to call graph is if you don't
you will in a minute hopefully it's just
a name for graphs which avoid P far so
the path with four vertices as an
induced sub graph okay so here you can
check it maybe but that's a cool graph
but if I add an edge here at the bottom
that's a disconnected program if I add
an edge on the bottom now I have a
ninja's copy of people so I'm not a
choreograph anymore or if I remove that
edge I'm also I have my digital copy of
P my endoscopy of Bitcoin I'm also
called
so this have been studied in a variety
of domains and we'll see an equivalent
definition a bit later on The Talk they
are also called complement reducible
graph
and the question I want to discuss in
this talk is if you take a uniform
random core graph with n vertices what
can you say about it and I will discuss
two aspects of that question the first
is what is this graph limit
and the second one is do we have large
independent sets and clicks and there
are some motivation for that you can
really look a bit arbitrary say it like
that but in fact
so this case when we avoid P4 if you
compare to other family of H3 graphs
it's Hazard special so I will explain
why in the first part of my talk and the
limiting objects
is a limiting graphene object turn out
to be rather different that what you can
see in other cases and I want also to
convince you that it's an interesting
really non-trivial limit that we find
here so one of the important points here
is that you're dealing with induced
subgroups yeah so they're not allowed to
be any edges along the Three Edge Parts
exactly so that's why
here I have a free Edge path here it's
induced so that's not local graph I had
it here also but here as a ninja sub
graph you will find the fourth cycle so
it's here this one is a code I see thank
you so it's you can
it's not a monotone class we sometimes
like adding edges you feel like the
conditions sometimes by deleting images
you you feel like it's a condition so it
still has induced.gov
and yeah and for this second question
the reason we look at I I will tell it
in the middle of the talk on so it's
related to what is called what's
famous few conjecture in graph here
which is the other channel conjecture
but okay it's just related it's not
really living in any
[Music]
nutrition on Saturday or any any really
progress
okay so the first part before going to
this guard for limit and independent
sets I want to discuss uh how asymptotic
enumeration of HP graph in general and
on core graph in particular there will
be no new result here it's more for me a
way to show you a bit the structure of
this H3 graphs and an introduction to to
the rest of the talk
Okay so
let's let me try to explain you
not to give you directly the result of
of how what a scientific result on
enumeration of HP graphs but to tell you
how very very clearly comes from so
imagine if you want I will just explain
lower bound because it's easier you just
construct some some H3 graphs and and
count them and if you want to say you
you're given an h and say you know it's
chromatic number so then chromatic
number I think it will be uh
it will be five in my in my example so
if you then there is an easy way to
construct a lot of H3 graphs is to
consider graphs on of that kind so what
I mean by of that kind you take
four colorable graph so it means you
take from independent sets and then you
can put whatever you want in the middle
so of course this will avoid the age in
fact not only as in your subgraph but
really a sub graph
and it's a easy counting exercise to see
that there are at least that there are
roughly two to the one minor scale 1
over K minus one plus a small o of one
times binomial N2 search Cups so
basically the conversion of edges which
are uh inside proportion of potential
edges of the complete graph which will
be inside one of this bubble if you take
this rather balance will be one over K
minus one so here K minus one is four
and that's why true you have to remove
such here okay so this gives you first
lower bound on the number of H3 graphs
we find vertices
and this will work also if you if you
look at things avoiding HS subgraph but
now we want inducer graph so you could
also do the same with say the comma
taking H bar instead of H because of
course this notion of induced graph you
have the number of H3 graphs will be
used in the same as the number of H bar
three graphs
and which means in terms of my picture
here is that
h-bar will be the complement of H sorry
so you you just
so in terms of my picture it means here
if like uh my chromatic number of H bar
is 5 then I will put Clicks in all of
this set and I will construct a lot of
age of H3
of HP gloves okay and in fact I can also
play and put sometimes independent set
and sometimes clicks and what you get at
the end is that
you will get this bomb not only if the
chromatic number of H is K but more
generally if you can partition your ER
if you cannot partition your set in
your vertex set of H in s clicks or
anti-independent set for some S Plus T
is equal to K minus 1. so
and then you can really take the best K
which the the best K which which
satisfies that and in fact what was
proved is that this gives you
it's a good uh asymptotic enumeration I
mean the good uh exponential uh
the good order of magnitude in the
exponential term when you try to
enumerate a trigger so that's this 3om
so the the definition of this R is a bit
complicated it's the maximal after that
you cannot partition things into ice
clicks are independent sets it's
something that R plus one is called the
coloring number of H so it's a variant
of the chromatic number where we you not
only consider partition in independent
sets but mixed partition in clicks and
independent sets and okay the hard thing
to prove is that this is indeed that you
have a matching upper bound I'll show
you how to get the lower one that's easy
but the matching upper bound is a little
bit hard so why now the clicks or the
independent sets of the complement right
that's how they enter uh yeah yeah
exactly but then you can mix clicks and
independent sets so it's not only this
is this will be smaller than no this
will be at least the maximum of the
chromatic number of your graph and of
the complement that can be bigger
because you can mix clicks and
independencies I see
and the thing is that it's hard to have
such a number small
here you see that the case if R is equal
to one this is really particular because
if R is bigger than one you really have
something which is a exponential of
theta of n Square but if R is equal to
one you have something of smaller order
of magnitude so you the case r equal one
is interesting
your complement need to be bipartite so
you already see that there are not so
many cases and you need in fact a bit
more and basically P4 is one of the
first few days so you have the edges P3
you have very trivial case but PIFA will
be one of the first one of the few cases
where you have really here a sub
quadratic uh bound here
and that's what yp4 is special and in
fact these photographs are rather easy
to to
enumerate by other method because I have
a very nice recursive structure
and
so this is a result from the early 80s
that in fact you have an equivalent
definition of photograph as the set of
graphs which can be obtained by
iterating these two operations so this
is just taking the joint Union and this
is taking design Union with a complete
bastard graph and adding all the edge
between the two sides yes
foreign
number it's not the chromatic number so
usually we will have like the complement
of H will not be bipartite and you will
have a bigger
in most cases
oops
so that's yeah
so you can obtain choreographed by all
core graphs by iterating this thing then
that's really an if and only if if you
avoid P4 you can be constructed like
that and if you can be constructed by
iterating this operation you are very
different and once you have the
statement that's not very difficult to
prove so that's why they are called
complement reducible graph because
another way to say that they are
obtained by digital Union and taking
complement because this is just the
complement of the
this is Antonio of the complements so
okay and once you know that you can
really encode your code house by your
tree which tells you which operation
you've made to construct your core graph
okay so here for example this program
that I had at the beginning to construct
it from vertices by using these two
operation what will I do I should take
on that side it should take three
vertices and do joins between them so
here I'm already
saying using that this join is in fact
um
and associative operation so I use it
for more than than two halves
and for that side it's a bit more
complicated I start with two vertices on
one side I do a digital engineer and I
start with three vertices I do the joint
Union and then I do a join in between
and then I took my two pieces and I do
additional tune-up so I think you'll see
how I go from at least more from the
tree to the core graph it's just by
iterating things and in fact the trigger
presentation you will be unique if you
impose that you have alternating uh
alternating decoration this Union and
plus I will call that decoration and
once you know that you can use
techniques from analytic Community
networks and have some very precise
enumeration results and we see that
indeed it's it's a exponential of a
small or often Square in fact it's you
have the N factorial if you use one
account in the level case but then it
will just grow exponentially and you can
say what is this constant you could also
say what this is this constant C and you
have this n to the minus three half term
which is really typical from
when you enumerate three structures
sorry
okay so that's the enumerating path and
we see already some uh y core graphs are
a bit special in this story so now I
will come
to the to the topic of the workshop and
we will type discuss graphical limit of
this model what and I'm interested in
really taking a uniform random graph
avoiding a given age as inducer graph
and to say to to say something about the
Carphone limits if it exists of course
yes
[Music]
just going back to your previous kit to
Kappa to the end is there a
representation of what you're
constructing as some sort of multi-type
branching process condition to be a size
n or something so yeah in fact you
if you just want to count you can even
do it with just one type because there
is a symmetry between union and plus or
another way to say it is that if I I
told you that this thing should
alternate so I only need to give you the
decoration of the root and you can
recover everything so which means up to
a factor of two you can forget about
this type
so it's really if you want to count it's
really one type branching process and
you can for example uniform random uh
core graph will give you a tree which is
a condition in galcon Watson 3
conditions we have a given number of
leaves I don't know if that answers the
question yeah exactly
and we'll
use that
okay so that's can you can you
understand the Kappa in terms of that
branching process
uh uh probably yeah I will not
please
yeah
the Kappa will will come you you need if
you if you want so here you have the
possible degree degree output so I
didn't say but I don't have a degree one
vertices so you have a list of possible
degree output you have to tilt that with
some power of Kappa to get a probability
distribution and to get a what we also
to make one yeah and that's exactly this
cover I see thank you
this construction they give you a graph
can you say it came from a core graph
and can I say if it's a choreography
there are algorithm to do that but I I I
don't know exactly how they work but
yeah I think you can do it in linear
time
okay so that's the question we we're
looking so in the case where or I mean
this theorem is General it works also
for photographs it gives some some uh
some somehow partial answer that
this graphing limit of of H3 graph
typical graph on image there are other
special so they look all a bit like that
so it might be just subsequentially
limit I don't know if the limit really
exists
in other term what I'm describing here
are the graphone which are H avoiding
and have maximal inputs
and they are more or less stochastic
block model except that oh okay so I I
cut my thing into R Block so the r is
exactly the same that we had before that
appeared in the asymptotic enumeration
and in the out Outer diagonal block I
just put one half
while it's not really a stochastic block
model because here I don't necessarily
have a constant function but what I know
here is that it's zero one value so here
I don't know if you can read it what is
important is that it's uh this curly
bracket so it means it can also really
takes value zero or one nothing in
Middle
okay so that's that's always to give
some intuition somehow for for me it's
not a proof it's not even a complete
your sketch of proof but it's a bit
reminiscent of that picture you know
when you have all these edges this gives
you one whole thing
and here you don't exactly know what you
have yeah so in this construction how
many agents does this have is it close
to the external number
so in this construction how many Edge
does the graph
how many Edge does the graph have a
uh for this part I don't really know
then here you will have like a function
close to one half if I when R comes is
big
yeah I'm sort of trying to understand
how far is the number of edges from the
extremal number
yeah because you like it's like replace
for triangle
if you want you can put you can just
take the complete graph unless H is a
click
but then there is a notion you have to
twist a bit the notion of external graph
if you want to to give it a sense in
this contraction I mean if you really
just care about number of edges it's far
it's like complete bipartite would be
extremely for triangle but he would you
would rather get a random bipartite so
there would be 50 of if you count the
edges but it's sort of a typical
triangle free graph
I mean
I'm gonna replace this one off by one
and it will still probably be uh H3
but then you will have a smaller entropy
so it's
yeah we are not optimizing it it just
counting in in either direction
okay for
two basically that you have one block
which is zero one value and somehow we
already know that in any FIFA world is
zero one five so that's not too hard
so what is the limiting form for for
FIFA and so we have this result and
which was also independently obtained by
by stoffler that if you take a uniform
random core graph so I said you have two
ways to Define that level one level I
don't want to go to the details so the
theorem works for both
and then you take the associated form it
will converge to some random raffle so
it's a convergence in distribution in
the space of Carphone and which is
related to The Burning motion so we call
it veronian
and here is the description of how you
construct it you start with a burning
Excursion is motion which starts at zero
comes back at time one at zero and is
always uh positive
and you have to add some Randomness you
have to take random sign to assign
random sign to each of its minimum
and then what we would we will do is if
I take X Y in 0 1 so I can
I I don't put that on my picture sorry
so I should have done that so X Y uh in
zero one so that's my interval 0 1 so I
can imagine I have points in my
Excursion then I look at the minimum of
the Excursion between X and Y and I look
what sign I see if I see a minus I just
put 0 for my graph 1 and 5 0 plus I put
one so I will give an intuition of why
this is a good definition in the next
slide but such as the definition
no so you look at the minimum of the
Excursion on X Y it's almost surely
unique so you will see some minus and
plus but you really see look at the
minimum which has a minimal value
Global minimal on the internet
and if you want that's a simulation so
that's a uniform random code half and
that's the adjacent symmetrics with one
being black and zero being white and we
see that it has a rather half structure
a bit with some self-similarity which
okay is related to the fact that we have
this one and limit
uh just I will try not to do a proof but
to explain you why uh why this is
reasonable definition for the limits and
the idea is really in this in this three
encoding so
your graph is encoded by your decorating
tree and in this encoding the vertices
corresponds to the leaf of the tree and
then you did the operation to add edges
okay you can think at it like that and
if I talk if I take these two leaves
also call it when I have the
corresponding vertices
connected in the corresponding
choreograph
it's easy in fact to answer this
question I just have
I just have to look when I did when I
put when I do my recursive construction
where when these two vertices are
brought together did I do additional
Union in which case they are not
connected or did I do a join in which
case I will be connected because I add
all edges so here
I didn't join because I have a plus here
so here means what in the first common
ancestor between the two leaves I had a
plus for the two corresponding vertices
are connected if I had a union
sorry there were not so you just have to
look really at this youngest common
ancestor in in the discrete that's how
you you can reconstruct the graph and
the nice thing is that you don't have to
construct orthograph if you want to ask
just if two vertices are connected
and so now what is the The
Continuous analog of that
so there is a whole theory of limit for
random 3 which has been developed a lot
in the last 30 years and now since in
particular it's this tree is in fact a
condition uh branching tree or golden
Watson three we know that it will
converge to what is called Aldous
Continuum random tree so what is that I
wanted to
let me redraw I say this coded by
auburnian Excursion so let me draw my
Excursion so you take your Excursion
like that
and now I will identify
pairs of points which are at the same
height
and such that everything is in between
they see each other everything in
between is higher and if you do that you
can imagine that you get a continuous
tree at the end and that's what is
called the Continuum random treat
Infinity
and in this story
the leaves which corresponded to
vertices in the discrete they just
we can prove that almost every element 0
1 corresponds to some point in the
description and it's it's in fact almost
surely a leaf in the graph
so the leaf will form will be basically
zero one in practice to measure one
subset but we can change with zero one
and what is I want to look when I take
two leaves I want to look at the
youngest common ancestor and if you
think that you have I take two leaves
here and here I have do my gluing
operation you can convince yourself that
this youngest common ancestor will
exactly correspond to the minimum of the
Excursion in this interval
and thus the definition is very natural
I just copy what I had here I connect X
and Y if the sign of the common uh an
ancestor is Plus
uh there are some subtleties that I'm
hiding here in the intuition is that for
example here I had some alternation of
of the decoration here I told you I want
to take I did the question but okay
it's uh still I think it starts we start
to understand why this can be the
limiting object
so if you don't like uh onion Excursion
I I have a good news for you you can
also describe you know you have this
Uber Fury you can also describe instead
of describing your uh your graphics as a
function you can describe it by as uh as
an infinite exchangeable graph so I I
will now do the finite the collection of
finite version for each end so I record
use this
gnwpr it's a graphic vertex at n and
such as a i and J are connected if
wbruary u j is equal to one and my UI
are IID uniform in zero one so the thing
which is a bit special here is that
since I have value 0 or 1 I'm not saying
they are connected with probability w u
i Ur but just they are connected if it's
equal to one okay and there is no
Randomness in this stage but what is
also it's different
so we have two sources of Randomness we
have this W1 systems okay and
but this give me for each n or random
graph and in fact this random graph has
a nice
uh discrete description
without anybody an Excursion you can get
it like that what you do is you will
take a uniform binary tree with n leaves
and I put random decoration
uniformly independently balanced
equation so our probability hard to get
a union probability Health to get a job
and I I don't have you see I don't have
my previous alternating condition
so this means that from a tree like that
I can construct a core graphs but
because I don't have this alternation
condition some core graphs will be
obtained for from
more than one tree so I don't have I
have a construction but I don't have
bijection anymore
and but okay you can do that you get a
random core graph which is not uniform
because some code graphs are obtained
from more trees than others and but
that's his distribution is exactly that
of gnwbr
and this also means that if you want to
prove that something compared to this
wbr is this
you can use the subgraph density
Criterion and you can just prove that
the sub graph density will converge to
so to those of the uh to to the
probabilities to the distribution sorry
of this random graphite chain so
you don't have to to deal with only an
Excursion you know we in fact the proof
of the pom once you have this
proposition is just combinator X we do
some counting argument and we prove that
we have the good limit for the support
density
but okay the intuition is really that's
the Excursion of encode
another nice thing I will go maybe fast
on this slide because I want to go to
the independent side part but another
nice thing to to of this is that in fact
if you look at its expected degree
distribution is just a uniform
distribution and zero and this tells you
that if you take a random vertex in a
random core graph its degree will be
normalized by n will be asymptotically
uniform in zero one just because it's uh
degree distribution is a continuous
functional on the spatial curve
okay so now I go to the independent sets
part and first I want to give a bit of
of motivation
so I said it's related to this channel
conjecture so let me tell you what it is
if you if you haven't seen it
um before you go on to the third part a
quick clarification question you know as
you mentioned briefly there are other
graphs where r equal to one so do you
expect or maybe it is immediate that in
this case all subsequential limits must
be zero unvalued whenever r equal to 1
uh yeah so that's that's uh result in
the paper of uh of hatami second that I
was citing and it's also true if you
avoid more than one
uh graph as in your sub graph and you
can even avoid an infinite family so
it's true for every hereditary classes I
see thank you
it's a good definition of such a class
which is
is the following if you take
if you fix your graph you want to avoid
then you have some Epsilon such as every
HP graph container homogeneous size or
homogeneous set of size and to the
Epsilon and this means either a click or
an independence
and of course it's very different if you
don't say that you want to avoid
something we know that login will be
best possible so this is saying we have
really
when you put some constraint you have
really bigger homogeneous
okay
is that an asymptotic conjecture does it
hold for n equals one for example if you
take Epsilon sufficiently small you can
make it known asymptotic
maybe then if you want to optimize
Epsilon it's better to set to to ask the
question what is the better Epsilon
subject for and sufficiently largely
have something of size adhesden to the
Epsilon but if you like this you can you
don't need to quantify it okay it's all
foreign
so when you have a conjecture like that
and you cannot prove it it's open when
sooner or later you might ask is it at
least true for a uniform random class so
and it was proof that indeed it's true
if you take a uniform random H3 graph it
will have a homogeneous set of size and
to the Epsilon with high probability
and in fact you have a bit more than
that that in most cases so for most age
you have something which is of linear
size
and
the question is that is it true for all
age of course and a natural since T4 is
special it's also natural to say okay is
it true for H equal P4
and that's basically the the question we
are we we
started looking look to look at because
we had already worked on this on this
random code UPS
and first what we try is to do some kind
of first moment method okay so what you
do is you fix some beta and you try to
study the number of independent sets of
size beta times and in a random graph of
size n and because of this 3D
description we can analyze that and it
turns out that you can compute the
expectation and this goes exponentially
fast if beta is not too small so we you
can even
uh compute the the exponential growth
height so here is a small plot until it
seems that until a bit more than one
half you have exponential growth
so this could indicate that there are
typically large independent sets of
independent set of inner size but in
fact we realize also in parallel that
it's not the case
so this the expectation is misleading so
it's basically Guided by your rare
events and that in fact typically this X
and beta n is equal to zero oxide also
for any beta or side otherwise the size
of the largest independent set in random
core graph is subliner okay and this
the proof of two so I told you one it's
a
it's a really a restrictor and analytic
combinatorics but for the proof of two
it uses the graph only limits that I
described uh if you slider code so I I
want just to to give you a glimpse of
how that works yes
yes this is your previous stuff you had
this sort of approximating uh
tree construction right where you put
IID uniform instead of like alternating
uniform suppose you ask for that
approximating tree these questions are
they also I think the answer will be the
same so for two I can tell you without
any doubts because what we prove is that
if if you take any sequence of graph
which converts to this phone then it has
a sublinear
largest independent set and of course
this approximating freezer this was a
sample from
so it's it's it converges
for one we will need to redo release the
computation but I I will be surprised if
there is a qualitative change in the
results
foreign
set for the Excursion
I will I mean so it's you have to to
take your Excursion
with the sign okay and then you have to
take some set of points such as each
time you take two points in your sets if
you look at the minimum between them
it's like it's like you have a minus we
don't have a more compact description
than that actually that was it's a
question
so okay
there is a notion of independent set in
a largest independent set size of
largest independent set of in a graphene
that was introduced by Lady and Russia
and it's really what you would expect
that an independent set will be a subset
such that the graph is equal to zero
almost everywhere on I times I and you
called alpha omega as a large the
maximum merger of an independent set and
that's an analog okay if that's an
analog of the of the size of the largest
independent set divided by n okay and a
nice thing that they prove in this paper
is that in fact this notion defines a
lower semicontinuous function on the
space of platform so meaning if you have
a sequence of government which W1 which
compares to W then
the limit or the limit shape of
Independence number of your WN will be
always at most Alpha of w so you don't
have the reverse inequality it's clear
that you could take WN is a constant one
over n graph one and then it has zero
independent set and and converge to
something which is all zero so as one as
independent number but in this sense
it's working if you if you have some
large independent sets in WN you need to
have a large independent set in the back
and because of that the only thing we
need to prove to prove that we have the
sublinearity is that in fact our money
and program has
almost surely no independent set or no
macroscopic independencies that's it
larger syndrome person that is zero
motion
so just tell you quickly a bit how to do
that we we need to use somehow we we
really work in the continuous and we use
the property of the of the burning
Excursion to do that
and the body and Excursion has a nice
self-similarity property which was
discovered by ardus
and here it's a very I will be a bit
imprecise but it's a thematic uh view of
it so what you do is you take your
volume Excursion
it simplify and you take 200.21 and you
then you look at the minimum between U1
and U of the Excursion between U1 and U2
here from its B okay and I will look at
the last time I was at the same level
as this minimum so it's a and the next
time I will be at the same level as this
minimum let's see and when you have this
is break your Excursion into three
pieces so the first two are easy to see
that this one between A and B this red
one between B and C and the third one
you have to forget and to merge the two
XML part
and that's the nice thing that put that
I'll lose proved is that these are three
independent excursions so you have to
scale them
by this random length it's just uh
therefore just follow the initial
distribution and also you could say that
okay so U is a random point in the blue
Excursion you have a bit more but for me
it's important that you get free
independent Excursion so if I put sine
of my on my Excursion this means that
from one ronian choreographer I can I
can decompose it somehow into three
independent copy of the burning
and I will try to follow independent
settings stories
imagine
so you have to imagine this card some
kind of girlfriend and if I take an
independent set of the large one on zero
one I can look at since its restriction
to the blue red and green part and this
gives me free independent set of my
smaller scaffold
but
here if I have a plus sign in the middle
it means that everything in the blue
part is connected to everything in the
red path so if I want to take an
independent set of the big thing I have
to choose I have to choose either I take
an independent set here or here but I
cannot take both
and because of that I get this kind of
inequality so if when I had a plus so
this is the size of my largest
independent set in my bigger phone this
is the size of the largest independent
set in the green part so I have this
rescaling Factor Delta zero which is the
size of the green bar
in the case where the sign of D was
minus I can take an independent set in
both the blue and the red part but if it
was plus I have to choose so I have a
maximum here and I get an inequality
like that and
I recall you this w i b r they are
independent copies of wbr so here from
this inequality you get a kind of
inequality for the distribution of Alpha
wbr and
we we could prove that by using some
kind of contraction argument and and
monotonicity because we don't have an
equation but an equation in distribution
an inequality in distribution but we
could prove that the only solution to
this equation in distribution is the
direct measuring 0. which means that in
that this Alpha BR is equal to zero
almost shown
so that's how the proof goes uh I like
that it goes for the continuous and the
self-similarity argument I find it
pretty but unfortunately it does not
give any control on the speed of
convergence and uh it would be nice to
to be able to say really what is the the
order of magnitude of this largest
Independence but it answers the question
which was asked about this uh P4 T4 free
graphing independent set of linear signs
so that's a pictorial summary of what I
said and I thank you for your attention
[Applause]
thank you very much are there any
further questions
so do you have any guesses for what that
should be the independent set like
square root n or something it's bigger
okay
yeah uh
we tried to have some some lower bound
it's uh and it's not that easy we were a
bit frustrating not to to get something
so are
the question is is will it be polynomial
in so two weeks ago I will have said
it's an overall again now I have some
doubts it could be polynomial
okay
so in the first row of your summary here
is there some graph for which the limit
is known to be existing
like strangle free or something so you
said the limit is like uh
for
eight three graphs when you fall when
you forbid only one H I'm
I mean
I don't know if this has been written
but there are some very good uh
description of like three four three
graphs and C5 free graphs in terms of
skilled graphs and generalized split
graphs at almost all FIFA Free graphs
are split graphs if I remember when and
from that you can you you can get the
limit
but if we fight for Titanics like zero
right they have smaller and square edges
nope
sorry for C then C4 it should be zero
here right I guess right and for C5 I
guess you will get a zero and a one I
see if I I should check what are exactly
the structural result but it's do I mode
maybe in terms of your your nice Brownie
and limit how can you see that P4 is not
in it
um
it's a matter of interpretation right
I think it's not
he
should not be
I mean in the discrete you can see that
um
when you take your iteration or you of
Union and join you can see that C4 that
P4 is not in it by just saying okay I
have my four vertices I look at the
first time they are separated by some
operation and you have several cases to
do and I guess here it's a bit the same
so you take your four vertices in your
Excursion you look at the first time
they are separated by your by your
minimum and then depending whether it's
minus and plus and how many vertices you
have on a child you can I think you can
convince yourself that it's indeed of
the past is not there or there has to be
an edge yeah exactly okay well thank you
very much
okay during the coffee then thank you
very much
[Applause]